does it feel kind of weird for you
it feels weird we haven't done this
before oh
okay caleb
[Music]
after admitting to just quote not
feeling it
there's
things getting in my head i'm realizing
our physical differences caleb aka mr
casanova finally gets comfortable enough
to take it there with alina
wait
maybe choosing a kids movie was not the
best idea
we've crossed a new threshold
anyway speaking of kids
who was already the mother of two boys
shocks mike by revealing that she can't
have any more children after acting as
if she could i really don't know what to
think
because we've talked about this on the
phone
about someday
wanting to have at least one more kid
now mike who has yet to have any kids of
his own is wondering should i stay or
should i go go go go go go go go we all
know it's not gonna be that easy for him
i'm gonna be really devastated poor guy
let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
surprisingly kim and osman who have
given us something to talk about every
week were no shows this episode i guess
they're saving all the drama for next
week when kim is going to go off on
uzman's team at his music video shoot
it's so unorganized it's terrible i'm
embarrassed for him boss lady kim is
going to come out and they don't want to
see that in the meantime while we wait
to see boss lady kim in action
let's talk caleb and elena i don't want
to rush into anything and end up hurting
alina or myself in the process all right
quick refresh after talking online and
over the phone for 13 years that's
dedication alina who was from russia and
caleb who was from arizona met for the
first time in turkey where were mekados
during their first night together caleb
chose not to be affectionate with elena
he didn't even give her a peck not even
a little
no
which caused elena to feel a bit
insecure
my feelings are kind of hurt because i
want some affection from him i like him
well the next day she got some affection
alright alina and caleb had a nice make
out sesh which brings us to the top of
this episode good morning
how are you feeling right now
um good
this is our second morning here in
turkey together and last night i kissed
selena we didn't have sex
but
we got into a new level of intimacy so
we've crossed a new threshold while
caleb seems to be pretty proud about
crossing that threshold alina admits she
wanted more i wanted to have sex last
night she shares that caleb kissing her
passionately but not taking it any
further it's confusing i didn't feel
like um
a need to push it all the way because
i'm still trying to you know get used to
some things and just
adjust to being
with you actually physically there's
you're different than some people like
that different so it's like hard for you
to
really take all in
it's just it's sometimes difficult
because we're
different heights
it's like i have to be crouched down to
really be next to you i just want to say
kudos to the communication here
i can only imagine how hard this is for
alina to hear
but i have to say
i respect caleb's honesty
to me
it's a sign that he wants to figure out
how to get past the thoughts that are
stopping him
know that i care regardless of how you
know what you might want to assume just
know that i actually care and the only
way to do that is to be honest
completely honest about the way you feel
all right go for it after their chat in
bed alina joins caleb at the gym and
later on in the day they have dinner
with alina's friend who lives in turkey
but once they get back to the hotel
[Music]
it goes down
and next week alina is going to tell us
all about it
well she's not going to tell us she's
telling her friend elijah but
same thing so girl now spill the tea
i took ride on his disco stick
literally
yes girl
she said a ride on his disco stick wow
[Music]
all right moving on to ximena and i'm
being honest about being able to give my
kids my name is mike i'm from thiel's
new york and i'm 34 years old now before
we start feeling bad for this sweet
innocent face let me give you some
background information about these two
and i'm warning you now
it might blow your mind
and if it doesn't
shout out to you for living life on the
edge
michael keep an eye on those pancakes
cause they'll burn on one side all right
when it comes to mike he lives at home
with his dad and grandfather who he
helps take care of barb are you ready
for your hearing aids
i hear what i want to hear believe me i
know that's right grandpa
also fun fact mike hasn't had a
relationship in the last 20 years or so
and once again he's 34 so since 14. in
high school i had a
somewhat of a serious relationship
it was for about a year
that pretty much sums it up he met
ximena who was 24 years old and lives in
columbia online and they've been talking
for about a year
now that we have mic covered let's get
into ximena
before mike arrives in columbia to meet
her in person for the first time ximena
opens up about the fathers of her two
boys juan who was nine and harold who
was three
eh
she explains that juan's dad was just a
one-night stand and her youngest harold
his dad is in prison
based off what she said i'm assuming
he's locked up for murder
and this is where things get real
interesting ximena goes on to tell the
story about how she got pregnant with
harold being that his dad is behind bars
and if you don't speak spanish please
read the subtitles because
this is deep and i want her to tell it
is
[Music]
this wasn't one of those you've been
down with me for years and i just so
happen to get locked up and we decide to
have a baby no they met on facebook
while he was locked up and she decided
to get pregnant by him i don't know
ximena's life so
i'm trying not to judge this is
different but i'll be honest my first
thought is how fair is that for the kid
she got pregnant with harold knowing
that his dad wouldn't physically be able
to be there for him
i guess that's why she's so open to
making things work with mike who plays
legos and puts his grandpa's hearing
aids in these are two totally different
type of people
and not in the opposite attract kind of
way
ximena says despite harold's dad being
incarcerated he talks to him every day
but now she's looking for someone who
can support her
aka
mike ximena shares that she was making
money as a nail technician but because
of the pandemic it's been hard so mike
who works in i.t has really stepped up
for her and bought her a number of
things including this couch this dining
room table this fridge
this stove
and a blender and a coffee maker plus he
gives her money for food and rent well
damn
my noise
ximena says mike isn't usually her type
but let's be real a man who provides
is a turn on for some people it can turn
a five into an eight real quick
plus mike is sweet
hola
so once he arrived in columbia the only
other thing ximena wanted to know is how
he is in the bedroom
responded finally brings us to this
episode
i know that was a lot of backstory but i
needed to make sure y'all knew what was
going on here also side note ximena
doesn't speak english and mike barely
knows spanish so their communication is
a bit rough but anyway take a look at
their reaction to their first night
together
our first night together um in bed was
the best time that i've ever had with a
woman um
amena knocked out of the park um i had a
great time over and over again
oh a part of me was hoping mike would
surprise us but
okay
they end up spending the rest of the day
at this beautiful waterfall with
ximena's family and ximena says although
mike wasn't great in bed she felt the
love so she's happy
but after seeing how mike interacts with
her kids who say he's the best boyfriend
their mommy has ever had
and after getting a nudge from her
sister ximena feels like this is the
right time to tell mike the truth about
being able to bear his children one day
okay
what do you have to tell me
[Music]
[Music]
ximena shares that she had a rough time
during both of her pregnancies so after
the second one she made the decision to
as she describes it cut her tubes and
have them burned so she for sure won't
be able to have any more kids
[Music]
after mike attempts to take it all in he
questions her about why she didn't tell
him this before why haven't i found out
about this sooner and according to
ximena it's because she didn't want to
lose him
which in my opinion means lose his
support there's always other things that
could be done mike then brings up the
fact that it's the 21st century and they
can probably find another way for her to
be able to have kids but ximena tries to
hint that what she did is irreversible
now mike is left with a lot to think
about i really don't know what to think
because we've talked about this on the
phone
about someday
wanting to have at least one more
kid
and she knows that
it's always been a dream of mine
if ximena and i can't have children of
our own
um
i'm gonna be really devastated
so i really don't know
where we're gonna go from here i need
you to run
oh if only he would
sweet michael he's so sweet and
obviously ximena is trying to make ends
meet for her boys but
at the end of the day it's about
integrity and how you go about doing
things she didn't just hold back the
information
it sounds like she basically lied as if
mike's dreams didn't matter in
comparison to what she wanted to receive
from him and next week she has another
confession a scary one
yo
i lived with a hit man
you'll see
it's just one thing after another after
another are you absolutely sure he's not
gonna come back and hurt any of us
[Music]
dang that's a lot
yes people deserve to be loved
regardless of their past but
it's also important that you feel safe
stay safe mike alright 90 day fans fam
we'll be digging more into this so
make sure you stick with et because we
are covering it all i will see you next
time
[Music]